[music]
>> Alhamdulillah.
Was-salatu was-salam ala Rasulillah. Wa
ala alihi wa as-habihi ajma'in. Amma
ba'd.
Fa'udhu billahi min ash-shaytan
ir-rajeem. Bismillah ir-rahman ir-rahim.
Ud'u ila sabili rabbika bil hikmah. Wal
maw'izhatil hasanah. Wa jadilhum billati
hiya ahsan.
Rabbishrahli sadri wa yassirli amri
wah-lul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu
qawli.
My dear brothers, I welcome you with
Islamic greetings. Assalamualaikum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa'alaikum
assalam wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
May peace, mercy, and blessings of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala be upon all of you.
So, how's everyone feeling today?
Alhamdulillah. Ready to go? Yeah.
Masha Allah.
That's really nice to know.
I hope brother Bushiri has done his
homework.
And he's going to turn out to be the
best, insha'Allah.
Insha'Allah.
And how about you, brother Ahmad Shafiq?
Ongoing, alhamdulillah. That's really
very nice.
Okay.
Before I read out the schedule,
normally in the Dawah training program,
after the first day, every following
day, we are going to have an interactive
session called as the recap session.
Wherein, we will, insha'Allah, talk to
each other about what was done on the
previous day,
and what you learned, how was your
experience
after going back home or after going
back to the hotel room, how did you feel
like?
So, these are some of the things that
which we will be doing every single day.
And insha'Allah, very soon, our brother
Athar Khan would be joining us to take
this recap session from, insha'Allah,
the day after tomorrow.
So, basically, I want to ask one
question.
How did you find this program different
from the other programs of which you
have attended earlier?
We would like to start with brother
Shafiq.
Bismillah.
I would say the magnitude of the
program.
The magnitude of the program itself.
Amazing. Masha'Allah. Alhamdulillah.
Brother Shafiq says that the magnitude
of the program. Magnitude in terms of?
Scale and all these cameras and
materials and arrangements. We have
always believed at IRF and Peace TV, and
this is the mission of Dr. Zakir Naik,
that normally people when they organize
workshops on management, workshops
related to the worldly things, they want
to spend more. But when it comes to
Islam, the Muslims always want to, you
know, spend less, spend less. Israf,
israf.
But rather for the work of Allah subhana
wa ta'ala you should spend the most.
You should spend the most.
You know, people
when they want to volunteer for the
cause of Islam,
you know, they think that as though they
are doing a favor on Islam.
They think that way.
But when it comes to the same business
meetings, they want to make sure they
give the 100% but volunteering
volunteering, right?
50%, 40%.
This is unfortunately the attitude of
the Muslims.
When you're doing the work for Allah
subhana wa ta'ala, for his deen, then it
has to be 100%.
And that is what alhamdulillah we
believe in and we try to give the best
in terms of magnitude, grandeur, and as
Dr. Zakir Naik rightly puts it,
unique and the best.
Inshallah. Jazakallahu khairan, brother
Shafiq.
Can we move on to brother Fadhli?
Salam alaikum. Wa alaikum assalam wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
Alhamdulillah.
I am feeling energized and motivated by
the whole entire program. Masha Allah,
IRF has done the best and this is so far
the best da'wah training that I have
went through. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah.
And what was the most interesting
session that which you found yesterday?
Alhamdulillah, all sessions were
interesting, no doubt. But there is
something one
Number two, number three. Which was the
number one for you yesterday?
Number one for me was uh
getting the my first chance to be on
stage. Alhamdulillah. And um
saying about other than previously we
have like more to like studies, we
go up to the stage, you know, but there
is part of the curriculum. But now is on
a different
platform which is da'wah solely and is
for the sake of Allah, inshallah. Yeah,
so everything is put on a different
level totally. Alhamdulillah.
Alhamdulillah. Jazakallahu khairan,
brother. Can we move on to brother
Kamarudin Abdullah?
Alhamdulillah, right from the day
brother Kamaruddin Abdullah has arrived
in Mumbai, we have found him mashallah
to be a fun-loving,
a witty, as well as mashallah a good
Muslim, illa mashallah, a good Muslim,
alhamdulillah.
So, brother Kamaruddin, you have been
into this field of dawah.
You have mashallah delivered more than
900 lectures as you mentioned it.
So, what difference do you feel in the
lectures that which you have given
earlier
and the preparation that which you see
here in this training workshop?
As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, Sheikh Halim, and to all my
brothers. Wa alaykum as-salam.
>> Alhamdulillah, subhanallah,
alhamdulillah, mashallah, tabarakallah.
I'm speechless, especially after 25
years in the world of dawah. In fact,
the mission to have
something like this is always in my
heart, but it been achieved by Dr. Zakir
Naik earlier. As did I say, he's did
plus. Now, I couldn't imagine Dr. Zakir
Naik have produced something I really
This is what I used to say in a 900
lecture. For Islam, we are giving very
little. For Allah, we giving little. But
for dunya, we are perfect. We want to DO
PERFECT. FOR DAWAH,
we must give Jannah class, not world
class, Jannah class. So, alhamdulillah,
Dr. Zakir Naik have given us Jannah
class. Believe me, I couldn't imagine
such a
fantastic, fascinating training, WHICH I
FEEL NOW I DON'T DESERVE to be sitting
here.
Because the discipline is so great and
the vision is so mashallah. At least, I
can go back home like his son, Farid
Naik. Alhamdulillah. Inshallah.
Better than Farid, inshallah.
Isn't it, Farid?
Can we move on the mic to Farid? But
before you speak, Farid, jazakallah
khairan for your words, brother
Kamaruddin.
But as you said, that Jannah here,
you know, I I disagree on this.
Rather, hadith of Rasul Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam clearly says that Jannah
is something that which no eye has ever
seen, no ears have ever heard, and your
brains or your minds can never imagine
it.
Insha'Allah, Jannah, which is our goal,
which is our mission of life. This is
just the way.
The goal is Jannah. The goal is not
Dawah. The goal is not this Dawah
training program.
The goal is to attain Jannah.
The pleasure of Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala.
So, Insha'Allah, we pray to Allah that
we reach Jannah Insha'Allah through this
Dawah training program. Insha'Allah.
Jazakallahu Khairan for your words. Yes,
Farik.
Masha'Allah. Assalamualaikum Wa
Rahmatullahi Wa Barakatuh to everyone.
Insha'Allah.
>> Assalamualaikum Wa Rahmatullahi Wa
Barakatuh.
Firstly, I would
say that may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
help us through this Dawah training
program to have a very pure intention
because the intention is very important.
Ikhlas is very important. So, whatever
Dawah training program, whatever
techniques, whatever we are learning, it
should be only for the pleasure of Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. And secondly, I would
like to say that as far as the
professionalism is concerned, it is
really very good because as you were
stating, that when it comes to the
dunya,
we are very forward. We want to spend as
much money as possible. But when it
comes to Deen, we are very backward. We
want to spend
very less and want to just get away with
it.
So, as far as the Dawah training program
is concerned, Alhamdulilah, it is going
on a very professional and international
level, and may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
accept the work of IRF
and all of our efforts, Insha'Allah. And
may Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala reward us
for all that we are doing, and may he
keep our intentions pure, Insha'Allah.
>> Amen. Amen. Jazakallahu Khairan for your
wise words, uh Farik. Masha'Allah,
though you are young, you are an example
to the youth of the day, Insha'Allah.
And I pray to Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala
that you remain to be a good example to
the world, insha'Allah.
And as was mentioned by brother
Kamaruddin and brother Farik as well,
also believe that you are our
guests.
More than the guest, you are the da'is
of Allah subhana wa ta'ala.
And a da'i of Allah should get the best
of reception.
We give the best of receptions to the
heads of the states,
to the diplomats, to the ambassadors,
but you are the ambassadors of Islam.
You deserve the best.
So, insha'Allah, the grandeur and the
arrangements that which you see is
solely based on this mission that which
we believe in, that for the work of
Allah, we want the best.
We will not compromise for even the
second best.
Forget about the third best and the
fourth best. We are not ready to
compromise even for the second best.
Alhamdulillah.
Brother Ibrahim, you have something to
say?
Alhamdulillah.
It's challenging,
but it's a good kind of challenge. It
pushes you
to do the work that
you won't push, you wouldn't necessarily
do.
For example, alhamdulillah, first day
we're made to go on the stage and speak.
Alhamdulillah.
So, it's challenging in the right way
because of Allah subhana wa ta'ala. Mhm.
Were you nervous, brother Ibrahim?
Still am.
>> [laughter]
>> Alhamdulillah.
Subhanallah. How many of you felt
nervous coming on the stage, coming on
this stage especially?
Be honest.
The majority.
The majority of them. Subhanallah. But
insha'Allah, we hope
not by the end of this training program,
maybe by the first half of this training
program, insha'Allah, every one of you
will get rid from this nervousness of
the stage, the stage fear that which we
say. Insha'Allah, we hope that none of
you would feel the same
of this training program, insha'Allah.
Yes, brother Zamri.
Masha Allah.
Should we give the best well-dressed
award to brother Zamri?
Brother Zamri, wouldn't you mind it?
Bismillah Rahman Rahim. Assalamualaikum
warahmatullah wabarakatuh.
>> Waalaikum assalam warahmatullah
wabarakatuh.
Okay, the question was
what are the thing that uh
we can get here but we cannot get
outside, is it? In other training.
>> How how is it different? Okay. Number
first, I believe no matter where I go
for the training also
Dr. Zakir Naik won't be there.
So, it is my pleasure in this training
Dr. Zakir was here.
So, that is number one.
Second that hit me on the dot yesterday
was
the three thing.
You see, when we want to do dawah we
thought the technique is the most
important.
But yesterday I learned number one
Allah's help.
Number second
is the hard work.
And number third only come the
technique.
So, mostly before this I thought the
technique is most important.
But alhamdulillah yesterday I learned
something
that maybe I couldn't learn somewhere
else. Inshallah.
Masha Allah. Jazak Allahu Khairan
brother Zamri.
>> [music]
[singing]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Amen.
>> [singing]
Amen.